hey guys it's Johanna here so let's get
down to understanding your body shape
and the best workouts to do if you are a
passion or an a shape you can't install
a local fat around the hips bottom and
thighs with a smaller upper body what I
tend to hear most is that you think you
look out of proportion so in order to
balance the body as a whole we want to
slim down on the lower body and build
more tone into the upper body what I
want you to do is to grab one heavy
weight dumbbell at least four to six
kilos or more this will be working on
your upper body there are no weights
needed for the lower body so let's get
started start with a quick 5 to 10
minutes warm up what we'll be working on
is strength training for the upper body
alternating with cardio for the lower
body to sleep down on your lower body
okay so let's start with the first
workout which is squad quick show the
press grab your way let's start on the
right hand side I want you to squat
slightly and give me a shirt press ok so
squat slightly twist your waist and give
me 10 short presses on one side good
that's it 3 down up so use your momentum
to bring the weights up for good
there you go 5 good 6 up if you're
struggling you can always dip a little
bend your knees and push it up good 7
straight up 8
9 this is going to be a nice tone to
your shoulders 10 good change side lap
side twist Bend slightly crucial get you
should find that one side would tend to
be weaker up 3 nice lens aim straight
posture for twist 5 fling out fix
breathe out on the way up
7 nice three more 8 good two more 9 + 1
10 good drop the weights
and now we want to work on some cardio
for the lower body love it or hate it
we're doing 15 per piece so get down
onto the floor and give me 50
let's go down up good
in order to slim down on the lower body
you need to add that many movements into
your workout get keep going that's 5 10
more down good remember when it gets
hard
what do you do breathe out
nine ten Oh was there five more to jump
together slimmer bottom one more ten
good job shake it out
now back on to upper body grab the
weights and we want to do lunge row so
I'm going to start with my left side
take a step forward the new body
slightly keep your chest up right okay
I'm roll it up bring your legs in step
back row alright so now we're working on
the last side of our back
good three down four knots just keep the
other hand on your hips five good step
back six seven squeeze make sure your
elbows are pointing back it squeeze good
nine squeeze in a way you are working on
your lower body at the same time good
Street side right hand side get ready
step back alright let's go one good
bring it in to squeeze your back not
three if you don't do this crap I have
your weight for give five nice release
gently six really
seven eight two more bend down low 9 + 1
10 good drop the dumbbells back onto
cardio to slim down on your bottom
okay jumping jacks wider jumping jacks
so step wide jump up wide and up okay 50
let's go one two I wanted to go no.3 low
or good then you go love 5 releases your
bottom-feeding 7 8 9 10
5 more 1 2 3 4 5 and just shake it out 5
strength training is to work on our
chest
I kid you want to make it look turtle
more lifted and anyway bigger as well so
who shops are the best someone to the
phone
the Guinness start when your knees 10
times okay this is what I call three one
who shops so start on your knees
count 3 times 1 2 3
ah ok nice and control to build muscles
2 3 up
good keep going 1 2 3
ah if you want to make it more of us get
on to your toes 1 2 3
ah good let's go 1 2 3
ah whoa halfway there nice and
controlled
oh it will get tougher let's get one two
three up three more hang in there Oh two
three ah - ah one two three ah good
last one nice and control two three ah
tighten your core at the same time very
very good back into our cardio for our
lower body in and out okay step forward
fifteen times
ready go one two three four five six
seven
bring it in eight nine ten
five more one two three four five very
very good
next strength training is to give your
arms a nice turn because chances are you
already have three bottoms and you just
want to turn it up so grab your dumb now
bring it back and what we want to do is
tricep extensions so remember to keep
your elbows close to your head okay
bring it all the way down keep your body
straight squeeze it up that's why let's
do ten control down control to always
remember nice and control do not rush
three good nice and control or squeeze
really feel triceps down five good now
six still track letter elbows are close
to your ears down seven good one two
three up eight two more ten your abs 2 3
up last one one two three and squeeze it
up
very very nice drop the weight and back
to your cardio kangaroo hops okay so
basic you smell like a kangaroo
touchdown for your own jump forward and
touchdown and jump back all right 15 of
those as well ready let's go down jump
two good three jump four jump five
remember in order to stay in the bottom
you got to have to do the jumping
movements eight good
let's get 501 like a kangaroo see you
touch three oh my god four yes I can
feel the burn 500 and shake it out now
let's work on our apps
so grab your weight and get down onto
the floor what we want to do is crunches
with legs extension okay only 15 times
up
crunch top as far as you can with the
dumbbells extend with the original back
touch and extend good three
only as you can four chances are if you
have a heavy bottom you will find that
leg extension can be tough because you
have more weights to carry seven good oh
eight nine ten five more
one really go all the way up to three
last two four five nuts
drop the dumbbells and the final workout
plug junk okay so get into a prone
position
all right palms on the floor and give me
15 times
jackass to go one two three four five
six seven eight good nine ten last five
one two three four five and just pull it
pull it pull it into your ass hole it's
nice breathe out pull and rest
relax and stretch it out with John so
just under 11 minutes
I've been approximately 108 calories
that's just based on my height and my
weight to make this into a full workout
repeat in at least once more or twice
more beginners go for two sets
intermediate three sets and those of you
who are more advanced go for four sets
remember in order to slim down on your
lower body you have to incorporate
dynamic moves I know it is tough moves
like jumping running they are tough but
they will help to slim down and burn fat
from your lower body and to include
muscle tone into your other body don't
be afraid to lift weights by doing
strength training it will turn upon the
other body and it will give you a nicer
definition so do this as a full workout
three times weekly and I can assure you
in four to six weeks times you will see
and feel the difference all the best for
new fitness food and motivational videos
please like share and subscribe to my
youtube channel and website do follow me
on Facebook Instagram and Twitter to
stay connected with me thanks guys
you